you know a woman would rather talk to a
to another woman going through the same
situation
in argentina right rather than her best
friend here in spain
so
so this is the importance of the
community it's like connecting women who
are going through similar situations as
as you are
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel and in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about a really
important topic that we don't talk about
enough women's health and fertility
welcome clelia morales co-founder and
ceo of womb a woman's health data
science driven company that empowers
women to understand their body better
and faster to increase their well-being
and help them make informed decisions in
cases needed
she's a digital marketing professional
with 15 and more years of experience
focused on how technology improves
people's lives and how innovation and a
diversified team can transform
traditional businesses and create new
ones welcome clelia
clelia morales welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from spain how are
you doing
i'm doing great really happy to be here
with you michael and talk about
important stuff
around women's health yeah we're going
to talk about very very important stuff
and these are the exactly the types of
episodes that i just love originally
you're from honduras you mentioned but
now you're in spain uh running a company
called womb
which is the fantastic name i think for
what it does and we're going to be
talking about women's health women's
fertility and and and you know what i'll
be picking your brain on in the next 20
minutes is sort of this intersection of
technology with with women's health and
what you've learned having run the
startup that has now over you know
almost 2 million people downloading it
from the app store and the google play
store
and i saw some incredible numbers i
think you mentioned like a hundred
thousand pregnancies uh according to
what your users are studying which is
pretty incredible 130 and now we'll dive
into
you see i'm already not updated and and
just as interestingly you're coming into
this role uh from being a marketing
executive for ebay with europe and so
i'm excited to understand your journey a
little bit better and i've talked enough
so i i'd love to tell me a little bit
about yourself and you know where you're
from yeah so i as i mentioned offline
right i'm originally from honduras i
grew up in honduras i i left
when i was on my early 20s and
and basically i lived in london
and i started off in consultancy um
always in in marketing incomes and this
is how i started at ebay spain i i
started as a communications director and
i moved quickly into an innovation team
across europe uh where we did stuff like
launching russia poland
um and uh and then i was um well i was a
social media director for for europe uh
which was
very nascent at that point so it was
part it was started off us as innovation
as well um
and then my last role was marketing
director for south of europe um at ebay
and uh and actually i i did like a360
right i i went through all marketing
channels and roles and um
you come up with a time like you you've
got such a great
uh experience such a great opportunities
career that it was time to give back
right and of course i've been
linked to technology all the time and
and due to personal experiences um
definitely i believed we could do
something specifically for around
women's health and it was also the case
of my co-founder glance
so tell me a little bit about this
moment where you're deciding that you're
going to give back you're looking at
what are the different opportunities
there are you know in the market the
different problems that could be solved
with technology what what what is how is
this does this process look from your
end before you decide to go into women's
fertility
yeah so this is not something that
happens from one day to another it's
something that actually i was even
working with with a coach right it felt
like it was time for a career change uh
and
uh and it's something that i was i was
thinking about for quite some time right
and uh
and and yeah so so uh i did have some
struggles some with health right and
realize how important is to keep a
balance right in in your
in your world and and i decided to to to
leave ebay because of because of this
right and how we can i could i could
make an impact on on women's health and
right so i touched base with my
co-founder and she she was in the same
process we worked together at ebay in
2006. she was at that point director of
marketing at google
and and she had she was going through
the same process right she was very
focused on fertility it really resonated
because i did have some challenges when
trying to have kids
and and this is why we started with womb
and this is why we started infertility
because it's something that we had in
common
right okay so walk me through the sort
of the founding story
you know you're deciding okay so i'm
gonna be working in fertility i'm gonna
be working on women's health
now what
you know what is the solution that we
need how do we know what the solution is
yeah we we knew where where we wanted to
go right we definitely had this vision
of making women international company
and a women's health company right but
we needed to start it somewhere and uh
and at some point so we decided
fertility spain right and it was like uh
it was very challenging it was just both
of us we actually started understanding
the ecosystems uh startup ecosystems and
we actually worked at started with um at
google campus right and uh and one
percent
without even
a powerpoint right we present with a wow
in a generated uh call um seed rocket
and we won the third place out of 200
startups so we we actually had to do the
powerpoint at that point
so it was it for us it was critical
right to be near a strong ecosystem that
helped us uh because it's
at the corporate world you have
everything right you have all the
resources and
and in here we needed to start i mean we
needed to create a company right and
find engineers and and find people for
products and
lucky enough um
there were some people from our our our
past that ebay like joined us from a
product standpoint which is was
fantastic uh we found some engineers but
and our our investors
so that that's another thing we put the
first money right
and and before launching the product we
did our first round and it was uh smart
money right and it was basically like
usual suspect investors serial
entrepreneurs from spain that actually
helped us right in this beginning right
right
right now tell me a little bit about the
space of women's fertility in women's
health so a little bit less on the
entrepreneurial side a little bit more
on you know looking at it from 30 000
feet in the air what are we looking at
and what are some of the the biggest
challenges that that women are facing
today that are either not spoken about
or maybe i don't really know because i
don't experience them necessarily myself
yeah it is it is a space that
we're beginning to to see some important
movements right and uh and and topics
but definitely
is an underlooked space right woman's
health in general
have been overlooked within time um from
products that haven't
haven't involved evolved really from a
woman's perspective or right or or even
clinical trials right not for woman
products not tested in woman
so um so there's definitely a gap um
there is um there is one one just to
give you an idea let's let's take an
example of endometriosis right is the
petrosis is a medical condition
suffered by one out of ten women
and it takes between eight to ten years
to be diagnosed
right mainly because um
on one side we suffer more in silence
right we think it's normal
and on the other side nobody's actually
paying attention usually you think hey
this is your period pains right so you
have to cope
and and when you try to have kids then
you realize you've been suffering from a
very painful medical condition which was
not normal
and you could have the i mean somebody
could have done something before
so um in case of fertility specifically
it is definitely a taboo right when you
actually break your leg you tell the
story to everybody when you can't have
kids you suffer in silence nobody talks
about it
and and it's it's of course a common
situation i'm sure uh you know people
that are suffering from infertility and
probably you don't know about
and uh so basically
to bring down the taboos on fertility um
much needed from a social standpoint as
well but from a from a woman's uh uh
standpoint it's as i say it's a big
suffering problem so um
we wanted to create something that can
help a woman
empower right understand their body
faster either to conceive naturally or
help them take the decision to see a
fertility specialist usually this
decision can take up to three years
right because uh couples
accept right they they need help
and as soon as they ask as they go to
the doctor that the faster they do it
their chances of of being of having a
successful pregnancy are higher right so
this is our mission help women
understand their bodies better
to make decisions right um
and see a doctor in case it's needed
right that makes a lot of sense now
if you're thinking from a product
perspective how do you
what are sort of the big steps that
you're taking to remove this taboo
because you know it makes sense why why
many way this is something that you know
many people would want to use but how do
you go ahead and change consumer
behavior when it's something so
psychological and personal
yeah i think it's it's about putting the
right product right i mean consumer
behaviors will take time
uh but um
but if you in in case of boom what we do
is is we do data science right so we
gather uh data that is related to
women's cycle to woman lifestyle
uh some biometrics and in case of
fertility we also gather male fertility
right which is critical sometimes that
is the problem of the partner and the
women don't know right
um
so
with all this data we provide um
very intelligent algorithms our
calendars uh forecast period forecast um
uh fertile window but we also have
calendars that are able to forecast uh
the the menstrual cycle of women with
long cycles these are women that they
don't really know when they're going to
get the next period and that means they
don't know uh how when they can get
pregnant right so so and this is thanks
to technology and uh and machine
learning right so we have we have that
on the calendar on the other side is
having a very personalized content with
all the data we have we provide content
depending on the goal of the woman the
profile of the woman right
and not less important but very i mean
it's it's it's the core of what we do is
it's the community right we have a
community of women um within the app
it's anonymized
because we know
uh
because of the topics you know a woman
would rather talk to uh to another woman
going through the same situation
in argentina right rather than her best
friend here in spain
so
so this is the importance of the
community it's like connecting women who
are going through similar situations as
as you are
okay that makes a lot of sense now if
you're looking at some of the things
that you've learned over the last
while working on this what are some
things that surprised you
about maybe the behavior of the users on
the app some things that you know you
you know you you're looking at them and
you're saying wow this is not something
that i would have expected coming into
coming into this world
yeah so
so um
i i think that uh on one side
it's not something that yeah i had uh
fully clear right when i started but
it's it's it's it's uh it is
which is the level of education we have
around our sexuality and our cycles
right how do i get pregnant how can i
prevent a pregnancy which seems very
very basic but again nobody talks about
them in the recent i would say right
three to four to five years things are
changing
um on the other side uh not really from
a user perspective but also from an
ecosystem perspective
um i i didn't think it would be too hard
to talk to male investors or let's say
first investors and then you realize
like 95 of them are male and we're
talking about the female products right
so it's very difficult
to an investor about cervical fluid
right because they won't they won't get
it right so
um so that's been a challenge as well
right that's been a challenge and um
things are changing the market is moving
the femtech market is moving right
um but there's so much to do um not only
on the investor side but also on the on
the product side and women's health
right now so from a business perspective
what what is what was the reception like
as you're raising funds for this for
this product and you're telling people
what you're working on
you know do you do do you find it more
or less challenging than a traditional
story because i can also see why and i'm
taking this as an example of simply
being you know an outlier from the
wealth of startups that may be happening
and you know pretty much every investor
or person that you'll tell your startup
to they're gonna be either surprised or
taken back in one way shape or another
because you're dealing with the vertical
that is just now being spoken about
right
yeah
so i think as i say i think things are
changing right uh but at the beginning
we had so many reactions like
uh and
i remember one of the funniest things it
happened when
i remember the moment when we had the
first user that wrote to us that got
pregnant when using the app it was like
a huge party at the office right it was
i think it was like wow three to four
weeks after we launched
and and still we received pictures of
the baby now she's four right over five
so wow so that's that's great and and
then the phrase like
um she got pregnant by womb and yeah i
got pregnant by one so it was it's so
funny right to to listen to that and uh
and it it's uh it's amazing from i can
i we can write a book around
conversations around book around women
and stakeholders and investors right
because we've seen so many things uh
like you know because one of the areas
that we think there's a need a right for
support of course it's um it's menopause
right at the end of the day fertility
it's something that not every woman
wants to have kids uh not every woman
would be challenged by fertility but we
all are going to go through menopause
and
and uh and it's funny because you see
that at the end of the day when you have
a couple a partner
there were some investors at one point i
remember when we talked we mentioned the
num the the name of menopause the word
he was like oh my god i need that at
home because my my wife is going through
that so
so yeah
but uh but yes or you know try to
explain we have a very cool project
around women's cervical fluid
so that is uh
yeah we need to be quite um
educational
and it's now we're used to it i love it
of course now if you had to
give perhaps a piece of advice to
someone who's working you know not
necessarily on on women's fertility and
health but on any subject that is taboo
or is not easy to speak about you know
what would you say to this entrepreneur
you know now that you've gone through a
lot of these hurdles
i think you need to be
bold and brave and understand your user
right and give the use the the moment to
the the tools to the user
that they can be as as vocal as they
want to be and and as i said community
to me is key um
for that topic right and if you know
it's always good to listen right because
we listen to the community we listen to
the emails we listen to everything they
they they um
they tell us and we try to provide the
right content for that
right it's it's don't right we have such
a fantastic tool
uh
as an app in my case right but again in
general terms technology
that we need it's it's such a powerful
tool that it's our responsibility to use
it correctly right and and help
your users across
this journey within their time within
their means right um but never never
stop on that never stop listening right
and give something back and this is
super important for us what we have
created at whom is a virtual cycle a
user will always come up and put up a
point of a data point and we want to
make sure they always get something back
right this is useful for them
so
yeah that would like
just just go for it but listening to
your users
thank you so much for these 20 minutes i
really really appreciate it before we
leave i have a couple of last questions
more about you but a little a little bit
less about a women's health and womb i
want i want you to take me back to
honduras growing up and as a kid what
really fascinates you
growing up what is sort of something
that really sparks your curiosity yeah
so i was and i think this is somehow
related so i was i was shocked and i've
been thinking about these rights like uh
two things uh that really fascinated me
one were athletes
right the endurance how they were
i was always um uh fascinated at least
watching olympic games i was it was it's
amazing right to see how athletics
performed
um and then the other one is
when i was more of a teenager it was
like human mind i you know one of my
frustrated careers is being a
psychologist right so
i read a lot about that and uh yeah
somehow i do rougher psychologies now
amazing and if you had to look today
what inspires you
on an on a daily level right so
obviously you're working on a very
important mission but on a very micro
daily level what are what is something
that inspires you in your day to day
yeah so this is a good question um and
and you know
to me right now i'm i'm really literally
obsessed about how our human body work
right and how grateful it is
and and and i'm trying to um
to do like optimization around my health
and my body and i can see like immediate
reactions right on
on the well-being we can achieve right
and of course the well-being we lose
when we don't do that so i'm just uh i'm
in in the past i would say two years
i'm really obsessed about how achieving
the right balance uh as a human being
right overall like mental health uh
um
your hormones uh your body how um
physical activity affects you how what
you eat affects you and and i'm
fascinated about the reaction of the
body right when you actually make this
optimization and and i just feel very
inspiring and i'm learning from a lot of
people on that and
and and actually teaching my kids
about it right it is uh it is i i feel
super inspired to see them yeah
and if you had to choose a few words to
describe yourself what would they be i
would say focused
um
definitely resilient if you're an
entrepreneur you need to be uh you are
resilient by definition
right i think those are are together
like focus resilient and persistent
that's why i consider myself
focused resilient and persistent claudia
thank you so so much thank you for the
incredible impact you've made on
now millions of of women
and uh and and i just love you know i
the sentence yeah i got pregnant by womb
uh i i think that's amazing and i can
only imagine the satisfaction that that
brings you know to your life and to the
lives of of the employees at womb and
knowing that you're literally making an
impact on women's lives and helping
create new life so i think that's
incredible thank you very very much and
stay safe and stay healthy thanks so
much michael for this time i really
appreciate it and enjoy
[Music]